I mean dude this is not
rocket science it's not rocket
science and you don't have to get into
all kinds of metaphysical narratives
about oh I came here to bring wholeness
to Earth or whatever it doesn't
matter all of that meaning
masturbation just let go of all of it
let go of all of it okay it's already
here it's already here it's already
apparently happening and it's already
obvious there's only there's only
apparent there's one thing that's
happening and it can apparently look
like two that one thing that's happening
is that it's already wholeness and it
can apparently look like there's a
contraction and a sense of me that lack
and is on a path for mutually sure
destruction that's all that's happening
that's all that's happening forever
forever that's all that's happening
there's either the whole or there's
assur destruction which is apparent Le
the
whole mutually assured destruction is
nothing but a contraction of wholeness
that's another way to say it mutually
assured destruction is nothing but a
contraction of
wholeness it's wholeness appearing like
mutually assured
destruction